[Music]
hi and welcome everyone to behind the
headlines covid and our children today
we're going to tackle one of the most
pressing and perplexing issues of the
pandemic how are children and
adolescents coping with covet 19 today
and how are they going to cope in the
future
my name is andre picard i'm the health
columnist at the global mail and i'm the
moderator for today's event
if you're not familiar with cfar it's a
global research organization that
convenes extraordinary minds to address
the most important questions facing
science and humanity and today we have
two of those extraordinary minds with us
let me introduce them briefly and then
we'll wade right into our conversation
candice auders is the cfar program
co-director child and brain development
and she's a professor at the university
of california irvine she's a
developmental psychologist whose
research cuts across public policy
psychology and neuroscience and we'll be
talking to her asking her questions on
all those areas and joining her is brett
finley he's the cfar program co-director
humans and the microbiome and a
professor at the university of british
columbia in vancouver he's a
microbiologist whose research explores
the interaction between pathogenic
bacteria such as salmonella and e coli
and their host cells and of course he
knows a lot about covid
so let's uh i just want to remind you
this session is going to last about 45
minutes i'll kick off the conversation
with a couple of questions and invite
our audience members to submit their
questions through the q a function you
can find it at the bottom of your screen
and i'll incorporate some of those
questions into our discussion uh the
session is being recorded and it will be
available a little later at
cfar.ca about next week we'll probably
post finally just a little reminder to
the audience that
the comments and opinions of our
panelists should not be taken as medical
advice and questions asking specific for
specific medical advice i just won't ask
them so don't bother us so let's get
right to it i wanted to start with you
candace if i could i want to ask you
just a really broad question to kick
this off
when it comes to covet and children
what what do you worry about the most is
it the virus itself is it the mental
health of children is the impact on
social development what are the big
questions that keep you up at night
yeah so i think um early on we learned
that children were spared some of the
worst effects in terms of physical
health and the the physical effects of
the disease itself but of course then we
started to wonder what is this doing to
kids learning to their social
development
we don't know that yet but what we can
think about is what's happened from kind
of past disruptions and when children
are taken out of the settings where they
learn they play they grow and of what
are the costs to that and i think we're
still starting to tally those so early
reports are indicating that there's been
learning loss um there's some concerns
around mental health although there's
some questions there but the one thing
that keeps me up at night is the
tremendous variability
and impact where those kids who are most
vulnerable seem to be kind of bearing
the the worst effects of the pandemic
socially in in terms of learning
so you're worrying a lot about the
equity issues that this this is not an
equal opportunity virus or pandemic yeah
that is clear this is amplifying those
inequalities that we worried about prior
to the pandemic and as children return
to the classrooms we're seeing even more
variability among young people
and brett if i can ask you the same
question what what keeps you up at night
when you you think of covert
well being a microbiologist my worst
nightmare and it is a nightmare is that
we get a strain that's resistant to all
vaccines because then we're back to
square zero and i don't think anyone
ever want to go through that again
regarding kids
i spent about the last decade in life
really showing and many others showing
that microbes are really essential for
childhood development and what kovit has
done is put these poor kids in isolation
and being a microbiologist i actually
worry about the kids microbes because it
had a direct effect on the kids health
and so by you know not going to day care
and not seeing you know other kids and
even not experiencing normal colds and
flus and things kids get and i think
this is directly related to what
candidates are saying because we know
these microbes can influence childhood
behavior development obesity asthma all
these things and so i worry that we've
really hurt our kids microbes and
we've got to figure out ways to get them
back to normal
and can you talk about that a little
more this is counterintuitive to a lot
of people that germs are actually good
for us so we want our kids exposed to
stuff we want them eating dirt can you
talk about why why that's important
yeah thanks for that promo i did write a
book called let them eat dirt and really
it's sort of a parental guide to
allowing your kids to interface with
their microbes because for the last 100
plus years since we first discovered
that microbes cause disease society's
been on a quest to get rid of them so
this is antibiotics this is hand washing
this is sanitation and we've done a
terrific job and get rid of infectious
diseases but the last decade or so we
now realize that
the collateral damages getting rid of
all these other microbes that just
normally live on our hands and our gut
and we now realize these things play
very important roles in childhood
development and so
yes you want to use hand sanitizer if
there's rampant diarrhea or something
but you don't want to be using hand
sanitizer five times when your kid's
going up and down the slide at the
playground and so you kind of have to
balance this hygiene versus the
microbial exposure and pre-covert we're
moving along nicely to convincing
everyone that yeah your kids can have
some microbes they're not going to get
polio anymore we're vaccinated to this
kind of thing let them play and let them
be kids
but now with code we've gone back
basically 100 years where the only way
was hygiene control and isolation of
things and so i think we're going to see
the effects of this as we go down the
over time
but let me just get you to elaborate
more on that is isn't covid one of those
microbes you want want them to get or is
it different
well covet is a virus so you know you
have the bacteria these things can
divide on their own viruses can't they
have to go inside a human cell to then
divide um
and there's no doubt to say the getting
covet is good for you um
it might help prevent infections down
the line if it's not too serious but
um when you wear a mask and you wash
your hands you avoid all exposure yes
you're avoiding covet but you're also
avoiding other microbial exposures and
we've seen a major plummet against say
for example flu rates and we know that's
kind of a seasonal disease there's some
arguments that getting flu actually kind
of helps develop your immune system when
you're young so you don't get flu when
you're older kind of thing
as well as all just the natural microbes
that we don't see causing disease that
we just actually know they're good for
us and we're just not getting them
anymore
so it's a complex question you've got to
balance hygiene for not getting sick
versus just microbial exposure and right
now we're way in the hygiene court and i
think we have to bring it back a bit so
we also get our good microbes for us
right now candace you talked about you
know developmental delays
in mental health in your your opening
about what you worry about at night
can you i want you to tackle the this
fearsome debate about should kids be in
school or not that's a is there a yes or
no answer to that one
so as a parent of two elementary school
children who were pushed off
online for schooling overnight and
someone who studies you know digital
well-being and learning yes kids should
be in school kids need to be interacting
with each other those social experiences
are not only part of their social
development they're actually part of
learning right so we know children learn
better project-based learning when
they're interacting they just they need
each other so
yes we should be doing everything
humanly possible to keep our children in
school and also in the other structures
that help support the development so
after school sports right we're seeing
rising rates of obesity among children
this was happening even before the
pandemic we need to ensure that as
children come back out of their homes
and into schoolyards we're opening up
all those opportunities right for play
for learning um and there's going to be
some challenges with us i also speak as
a
not just a researcher but a mother who
is just quarantined with an asymptomatic
child who had an exposure at school
right so how
how do we balance that risk versus need
to keep children in the classroom and
the pandemic is far from
from over for our families with
unvaccinated people and many of those
people are our children so it's going to
be a challenge but we we need to rally
to do that
and and talk about finding that balance
as a parent because people are all over
the spectrum i get lots of email about
this
how do you find that balance of when to
send them when it's not safe when it is
right yeah so there's a huge variability
in terms of risk tolerance and making
those kind of judgments um what we're
all being asked to do is make judgments
under conditions of huge uncertainty
when the stakes are high right the
stakes could not be higher than the
health of your children so that is a
very kind of stressful high stakes game
that we're all being forced to play
where where a universal policy is just
not going to give us the answer for what
we need to do so um there's some things
that we could do to help you know brett
can talk probably talk about the need
for rapid antigen testing making that
available for parents for people who are
working in schools right making it so
it's easier once there's been an
exposure identified to do that tracing
and ensure that everyone's
safe
but there really it really is kind of a
a mass lesson and having to
make daily decisions under huge
uncertainty and um varying levels of
risk that are changing every day right
as as the virus changes as infection
levels change in local communities and
we're all experiencing this very
differently um you know kind of at very
micro levels
and brett maybe you can weigh in there
from the other perspective how do we
make schools as safe as possible if it
is a priority to get kids there
yeah i think
most people agree that the kids do need
interactions with other kids to develop
normally i think that that's a given um
but then how do you make schools safe
and kansas has already really you know
talked about testing um i think um in
the next while we are going to see
childhood vaccines come along and it
does take a little longer to get these
things up and running but they're
working on it hard and i think that
hopefully that will come online too and
then you know um in a few months the
kids will be vaccinated and that will
ease the fears but a bit too
um but you're right right now it's it's
it's it's a bit of a crap shoot and you
you take your best guess while there's
not much code with my neighborhood right
now it's probably okay it's no guarantee
um
i mean the good thing is is kids do not
generally get as sick as elder adults
with covet
but they are a reservoir and they can
bring it home and if you have say an
elder grandparent living with you or
something that puts them much at risk
and that's where there's worry too so
it's not just the kids that come into
the equation it's this reservoir um
my wife is a pediatrician she vaccinates
some children and she says you're a hero
you're not doing it for yourself so much
you're doing for for for your parents
and your grandparents and your whole
neighborhood you're a real hero by
getting vaccinated and um because it's
not just for the kids it's it's all the
society we're talking about um so
it's a hard question and with no easy
answer
and kenneth i want to come back to the
socialization issue because it's a big
one with parents
is this going to have long-term effects
that you know kids sort of withdrawn
from society for a year depending on
where they live is it going to be a
long-term impact are kids really
resilient as they are with many other
things
yeah so kids are incredibly resilient
and i think that we're going to see many
if not you know most children bounce
back and when i started the we started
the conversation i talked about huge
variability some children have had even
more interaction during covet right so
they've been home and spending more time
with family members um i know that many
parents watching this will kind of
cringe and be thankful for the digital
world so social gaming took off during
this time as kids congregated to play in
online spaces in addition to kind of
having to go there to learn and so
social interaction um
you know
there may have been some isolation in
terms of the exposure on the microbiome
but kids are inherently social and they
found ways and tools to connect um
parents created small play groups you
know there were
but there was variability some children
and those in high-risk situations or
high-risk households um did experience
more of the social isolation as well so
we have to be be wary of that but i'm
i'm optimistic um that this generation
will not carry you know enduring scar
socially but we're going to have to
invest you know to ensure that they get
over this hump and through these
transitions as we move back to whatever
the new normal is
and this is your expertise so i i want
you to probe you a bit on this is
interacting online is that as good as
irl in real life
because you know we went from a period
where you know we told our kids to get
off the damn computer to be on the
computer all the time
yeah it's interesting as someone who's
been following young people on their
devices for the last decade um and
listening to parents concerns over this
to see the conversation flip almost
overnight from i need to get my kids off
my screens the screens are bad for them
so how can we leverage these tools
to connect kids to the things that they
want or need in life so to their friends
to their schools to grandparents that
are separated um which i know happened
in in our our household and so i think
there was an openness to figuring out
kind of what digital technology does i
think we also learned that you know
there was this myth that children were
disappearing into their phones and
weren't interested in in-person social
interaction anymore you know and that
was really never the case so what young
people if you actually look at what they
do online they spend a lot of time
talking to people they know offline
arranging to meet up talking about
things that they did and experiences
that they had offline so that the nature
of that communication changed a bit as
you took out the in real life part of it
um but the digital tech was never going
to replace you know what they needed in
terms of their face-to-face contact in
those social groups
okay and brett i'm sorry i cut you off
there
well i was just going to add that um
let's talk a bit about preschool kids
for example too um
from my point of view i'm extremely
worried about kids that were born during
covid um because it's a whole different
world they're born into and the
exposures they have everything from
microbial exposures to daycare to
grandparental exposures and we know that
this early period in life that's the
most critical for childhood development
um it's really the first five years in
terms of brain
and it's at this time where we're you
know we're if we've looked you know
forward i think we're going to see the
biggest effect in in these kids i'm not
so worried about the 12 year old and
stuff they're out there already and
they've acquired their microbes and
things i'm worried about the kids that
you know are born into a covert world
which is really an isolation world and
that's we are social animals and that's
not how we evolve biologically so i
think we need to bring that into the
equation as well
and candace can you comment on that do
you worry about the coveted babies who
aren't who aren't gaming yet who are
just babies
yes i think there's there's going to be
tremendous variability there and a lot
of it's going to become even more
dependent on the parents right and so
prior to this
babies and young children have an entire
network of people investing in their
early language development and those
early skills that they need right and
that's been shut down or restricted
somewhat so it becomes more dependent on
kind of who they're interacting with day
by day which raises the issue of how
well we're supporting new parents um as
a society and how well we're we're
putting structures in place there i
think you know janet worker at ubc also
they've issued a report from the royal
society of canada um advice for what we
can be doing to support that early
language development during this time
and a lot of it is offering parents
support around the serve and return type
of language do they typically be getting
a daycare about providing some guidance
around digital literacy and what types
of apps and learning online learning is
going to actually be helpful versus
harmful for those kind of core
skills so i think it's going to require
a new set of considerations but in
addition to this being an important
period of brain development it's an also
an entirely like plastic period where we
know that children can
seek from their world what it is they
need for development so it might not
look the same as it did prior to covet
in terms of the inputs but they'll be
seeking out their world around them so
to kind of elicit those social
interactions from um from places where
they feel they can get them
now brett i want to come back there's a
lot of interest in in vaccination i want
to come back a lot of people wonder
why is it taking so long to have a
vaccine for children we've had one for
adults well in coveted terms it's
forever about nine months
why is it taking so long for kids to to
get their shots
well the good thing is perspective
usually it takes 20 years to develop a
vaccine so these these mrna vaccines
have just been an outstanding stellar
lightning speed type production um but
but the regulatory rules around kids are
different than adults they're much more
stringent and they're much more on the
lookout for any potential harm etc i
mean last thing you want to do is is
inject something into a baby that then
has um prolonged um effects
um all that said they're coming um you
know and that the trials have been
underway and i think we're already doing
12 year olds plus we've got quite a good
vaccination rate going in canada with
them and i think the 5 to 12 year olds
will come online you know once the data
is in
at this stage i just say have patience
they're coming they use a lower dose
about a third of what the adults use but
they get terrific responses and i think
we'll come and we just have to let the
let the system move through as quickly
as it possibly can and they will come
but there will be childhood vaccine for
sure
and another flu relay another vaccine
related questions that someone's asking
should we still be getting our flu shots
uh especially if there's no we keep
hearing there's no flu around
there will be flu have faith
there always will definitely get your
shots i mean
you know we jokingly have shot parties
where my wife brings home flu vaccines
and we have tequila in one hand and a
needle in the other and
no flu shots are very important
kids do die of flu there's no doubt i'm
not it's not as bad as the older adults
but but it is a big issue
and there's no interaction between flu
and covid type things that anyone's ever
seen it's independent um but i think the
second week start i'm easing up on the
mass regulations um
like if you're vaccinated you don't wear
a mask you're still at high risk for flu
because it's an airborne disease much
like much like covet is so as soon as
those masks come off flu will come
roaring back and there's some thought
that we've really had a couple of
seasons now without flu and flu is just
kind of you know just sitting in the
corners there waiting to leap out on us
because here's this wonderfully naive
population has never had flu for a
couple years it's fresh meat from a
viral point of view and
they're going to be all over so
definitely get your flu shot another
thing is of course flu um put you more
at risk for kovid just because it
weakens you and that has caused lung
damage so for that reason too it's
another way of sort of collaterally
strengthening against covet by getting a
flu shot
now candace we talked about development
so far i want to talk a bit about the
mental health aspect as well we're
hearing reports of you know a lot of
anxiety lots of depression but on the
other hand we're hearing big drops in
suicide so can we figure out has this
been really bad for our mental health or
has there been good stuff with the
pandemic as well
yeah so we were actually experiencing a
youth mental health crisis before cobot
hit so um rates of anxiety and
depression were increasing rates of
suicide were increasing and there were
huge concerns even before cove would hit
and then i think as we followed it's too
early to tell but of those studies that
have followed
children adolescence through the
pandemic and they've been limited in
number and in terms of how we can
generalize but there's been a mixed bag
of findings and so some people are
finding actual reductions in mental
health problems and they're speculating
that the increased sleep that
adolescents are getting without that
school start time the reduced pressure
around testing and the over scheduled
children that we were seeing before has
released some of that anxiety
then of course there's the concerns
about the the stressors that covet has
um
has brought to families in terms of
financial medical stress
and isolation we've been talking about
so i think that the effects are going to
be
differential across um
across children adolescents we're not
seeing the big spikes in mental health
problems that i think some people had
anticipated and it certainly won't be a
uniform effect but what we are going to
need is screening as children come back
we are going to need
better coordination of mental health
services again which was an issue prior
to the pandemic
but what we've seen is telehealth right
that's come on the scene for our regular
doctor visits we know
young people are going online they're
searching for information and for help
for mental health problems online and
this might be an opportunity to connect
them to treatments and services and
providers that work so there are some
opportunities here to kind of leverage
the openness to digital health and
improve our treatment
and how do we distinguish between sort
of the normal human emotions it's normal
to be anxious during a pandemic and that
means a mental illness how do you make
sure that we don't uh you know
medicalize every feeling that people
have during the pandemic yeah so this
has been a big thing i mean we should be
depressed and anxious during a global
pandemic right i mean that's the that's
the appropriate reaction and i think you
know we see this um but if you think of
you know diagnostically how this this
plays out in terms of severity of
symptoms in terms of interfering with
daily activities which again is hard to
judge because our daily activities have
been have been changed
and you can get a better handle on
whether it's just a fluctuating set of
symptoms that might be dependent on the
conditions versus something that's going
to be more stable um and more difficult
to treat and i again i think because
young people have disappeared into their
homes and away from the places where we
usually are able to kind of test and
understand what's happening on the
population level it's going to be a
little while before we can get a good
read on both how they're feeling during
the pandemic and and how they're coming
out of it
yeah and i'll just throw this in because
it's coming in now in the question some
people are wondering is this going to
linger or will we just sort of magically
get better once we can get out and about
well i think what we're seeing now is a
bit of transition um
difficulty and anxiety i know i'm seeing
it you know i teach at a large public
university
students are back on campus but we're
seeing an uptick in reports of mental
health problems of transitioning back i
think we're seeing this among our
colleagues and our families as people
try and transition back to a world
that's
normal but not yet normal right so
there's
we're still in that time of uncertainty
so i think there's this whole phase of
the pandemic which is a transition back
to whatever this new normal will be
um that we really don't understand yet
right and brett speaking of long-term
issues there's some interest in in long
covert can do we have any sense of why
do some people have lingering symptoms
will they be there forever or is this
temporary any insight you can give us on
on long covert because particularly you
worry with kids i think
yeah um
the answer is no i guess we really know
very little about long covid we can't
predict who's going to get it what
causes it what it really is it does
happen in kids it's a much lower rate
than adults so that's encouraging but
there is some long covert in kids and
it's under intense investigation right
now but from what i've seen the answers
are very limited and um
yeah
i can't really offer anything
intelligent about it
so another another longer term issue
we've seen reports of obesity rising
again because kids are inactive they're
a little closer to the fridge all day
practical things like that is is this an
issue you worry about too the the
obesity problem which already existed
before covet
yeah of course and um you know wearing
my microbiologist hat um there's
experiments done many years ago where
you took
basically fat mice and did a fecal
transfer into thin mice and they gained
weight and vice versa and you could take
heavy people put their feces in mice
they they increased weight and what's
happened over the last decade or so to
now realize that micros play a major
role in obesity and really the simple
fact of how you're born so if you're
born by cesarean section you have a 30
higher chance of becoming obese than if
you're born vaginally because of the
microbes the mother's microbes you
acquire things and similarly with asthma
again same kind of story it's 25 higher
rate of asthma by c-section what does
that mean it means those microbes you
initially encounter from your mother and
in early life are really important so
again going back to these coveted babies
where they don't get the microbes that
they might have normally got
i think one of the long-term things
we're going to be looking for is
interest rates in both asthma and
obesity in children
because of the microbial influence in
their early life or lack thereof and
putting them more at risk
so yes inactivity and sitting front of
the screen will do it but we also know
that a lot of it has to do with the
microbes in the kids gut and how that
will influence both asthma and obesity
later on in life
and if we have some young researchers
online sounds like a good research topic
to to get in on what is going to be the
long-term impact on obesity so if you're
looking for some phd students maybe
there's some in the audience there for
you and now candace i want to come back
to you we talked a lot about kids but i
want to talk to you if you could talk a
bit about family dynamics you know just
being with your kids 24 7 is a very
unusual thing in our modern times we see
very little of that
what's the impact of that has that been
good for parents and children
detrimental
yeah so i think there's a again there's
a lot of variability and that's the big
story here is that um you know parents
have had very different arrangements and
their their work their ability to work
from home right and so some parents that
are working from home do have it at a
time with their children but again
that's the added stressor of if they're
also homeschooling their children at
that time so it's been it's been
interesting i don't think that we we
fully um
appreciate what's happening i think one
of the things we have seen is that
parents know a lot more about what their
children
are doing like so supervision has
increased and that's both in terms of
kind of academic progress and what their
schools are doing but also you know who
their friends are and what's happening
online so
um depending on the age of the child for
younger children they've enjoyed
probably having their parents around a
bit more um teenagers maybe that's been
a bit more mixed or stressful so
uh so the answers are varied i do i do
think what we're hearing and again this
is anecdotal that we haven't we study
adolescence so we get everything from
their perspective um that families are
making different decisions coming out of
the pandemic about how they want to
change you know spend their time
how much they're going to travel for
work you know kind of how they're going
to prioritize um kind of decisions in
their family about
about where they're going to travel or
where they're going to how they're going
to spend their time so i think we're
going to see family dynamics shift a bit
and that's going to vary a lot depending
on the freedom that parents have um to
make those kinds of decisions versus
some families where you know they've had
to actually work more and work in
precarious and dangerous situations um
and the stressors have increased
increase there
and i want to talk a bit about that flip
side early in the pandemic there's lots
of concerns you know not everybody has a
safe home they have a home but it's not
necessarily safe worried about rises in
child abuse
domestic violence has have those fears
been born out do we know
yeah so we have seen and locally there's
a group here that's been doing some work
with the children's hospital and the
domestic violence shelters so we've
we've seen kind of
mixed
results one of the things we've seen is
a decrease in the number of reports
which makes sense because there's fewer
exposures some neighbors teachers etc
are less likely to see
and report as mandated reporters but
we're seeing some increases in severe
injury and emergency rooms which
suggests that there are increases in
child maltreatment happening in the home
during these times and some of that is
just prolonged exposure some of it could
be added stressors but um it's clear
that you know this has been for many
families an incredibly stressful
time
and one that
has all the kind of ingredients that we
know
uh predict child maltreatment and
violence within the home
and it comes back to your initial point
about there's inequities here not
everybody's benefiting or suffering
equally yeah yes i think school has
always been um a great equalizer in
terms of putting in that safety net for
children and for families whether that's
nutritionally whether that's for social
interaction for education for monitoring
for signs of abuse and neglect and when
that's taken out what we see is that the
fate of children is dependent on a
smaller number of adults in their lives
and that can be dangerous territory for
many many young people
now brett i want to shift a bit uh
because we have an interesting question
that's different from mine
people are asking about science
communication both of you are very
gifted communicators
but they're wondering how have we done
overall and how can we communicate the
science a little better during a
pandemic bread if you want to start
that's that's a really good question and
um obviously andre you're in the thick
of it in terms of communications um yeah
i think it's been a really interesting
exercise um first of all at the risk of
getting um
virtually hit by everyone covets
actually probably the coolest experiment
going in a long time i mean when else
can you shut down the entire world and
see what happens so from a strictly
scientific point of view it's
fascinating to see what's going on and
how scientists are behaving and how the
world is behaving
i think most scientists are trying to
communicate i think the public's
frustration is they are getting up to
the minute communications and science is
changing and every day something changes
in covid and they say well last week you
said this but this week you're saying
that you don't know what you're talking
about and i think the public has to
realize that because because the
pandemic everything is out there in real
time and so
um you know you are seeing these changes
in wear a mask don't wear a mask you
know
all these types of things
i think generally scientists have tried
to communicate as best they can and a
scientist we just tell it like it is as
today but you have to realize that could
change tomorrow we don't have all the
answers as i think you've already
figured out during our discussion so far
we know virtually very little about this
whole thing and we're trying and we are
learning as we go and so i think you
know i think the scientists we're trying
to put out our best what we know so far
but we don't have all the answers and um
but it as i said it's a very interesting
experiment and it's ongoing and we're
living it right now and i think these
will all become apparent over time as
these things get studied more and more
i think scientists are trying to
communicate but i think the public is
frustrated because we don't have all the
answers and never will
yeah i think i often say that saying i
don't know is is often comforting to the
public they don't necessarily want
magical answers but they want to know
that it's okay to not not know right
so well they want magical answers but i
mean they're not going to get them so
the second best thing i don't know
candace if you want to weigh in on that
the communication issue how can we do
better
i i think brett is exactly right there's
so many things we don't know but there
are sources online and otherwise saying
that they do know right so people are
coming in to fill that vacuum with
misinformation and that's being
circulated as we all know very widely
and often more widely and louder than
legitimate sources of kind of
evidence-based science on this and so
you know we have i think we have a
battle on two fronts one is the
effective communication of what it is we
know and we don't know and the other is
battling the misinformation and we see
this so much with parents you know in
terms of silos of information that they
fall into and again the stakes are high
it's the health of your child you know
the need to know and not to have to deal
with this uncertainty is a strong pull
um and so that's gonna that's gonna
require some structural change that's
gonna require cooperation with big tech
that's gonna require some regulation
around misinformation um that's going to
require this generation which actually
in many studies they're better at
identifying misinformation than adults
are so um you know becoming more
sophisticated in parsing out what
science is saying and and where those
sources of misinformation and false
you know called false narratives are
coming from
yeah i think that's a really important
point we have to remember it's my
generation that's spreading the
misinformation the kids tend to be a lot
more savvy about this stuff than we we
old people
now there seems to be a lot of interest
your comments about covet babies really
caught the attention of the audience
from what i can tell from the questions
people are asking you know can you give
specific guidance are there things to
help the kova babies are there apps are
there programs people seem to be worried
about their their kids missing out
um well maybe i'll start and then
candace you can correct me
yeah i mean i i always
go back to go back to basics how does a
kid normally you know was bored and then
raised and um even in pre-cover there
was discussion what happens if you have
to a c-section how do you
get your kid normally exposed to
microbes and things so i think
and you know simple things strictly from
my microbial point of view is things
like dog in a house for example that
actually decreases asthma things because
dogs go outside and they bring in
outside in and kids licks them cat
lovers sorry there's no data with cats
they sort of stand in the corner and
sort of twiddle their departure i think
but and then just microbial exposures um
you know
let your kid go outside i mean
they're you're not going to get coveted
from playing in your backyard kind of
thing now maybe you get kova going to a
crowded playground but go when it's not
crowded um you know let your kids
experience the world um you know you
think how kids grew up you know a
thousand years ago i mean they're
outside all the time playing with many
different kids and many exposures
so so there are some concrete things in
that sense another thing is diet that
thing we haven't really talked about but
i think covert really changed everyone's
diet i mean i know i worked through an
entire bread cookbook for example i'm
going to eat more bread in my life what
did that do to my microbes we know diet
changes your microbes so
i think healthy eating is a that's has
major role both for health and also
microbial health which then translates
to health there so i think diet is
something to pay attention to some
people have been eating better during
the pandemic others have not um so i
think you know i'm considering that as
well so very practical things just think
okay what what am i missing due to this
pandemic and how can i sort of do a
substitution if i can't get it to make a
sort of normal kind of thing
and i think with that kind of view you
can go a long ways to
preventing repairing potential
detrimental effects
now brett i can tell from the chat that
you're scaring people about c-sections
so i'm going to know i'm talking about
that but uh
candace i wondered if you could comment
on that one the coveted babies there's
specific stuff people can do on the
developmental side or are there apps or
should you not just worry about that too
too much as you said before kids are
adaptable
yes i agree with brett and going back to
the basics i think one of the things
that we know that is harmful is high
parental stress right and we're putting
a lot of expectations on parents and
especially um among women who are the
primary caregivers of that age many of
whom are often juggling other
responsibilities and so um there's been
this
idea around in psychology for a long
time which is good enough parenting
right and so taking care of the basics
you know
diet social interaction the servant
returned language being okay if you need
to give your kid that ipad or put them
in front of a show so you can get
together and like you know take care of
the family and yourself right so there's
a parental care aspect of this also
there's you know the things that we know
that are important in those early ages
and some of it they can get from
siblings and other family members that
they are close to right that serve and
return language that everyday exposure
to literacy and reading you know people
have a lot of questions about
educational apps there's a whole variety
this is a you know multi-billion dollar
industry right now but there's some
really good research by developmental
psychologist patricia cool being one of
them university of washington talking
about what aspects of kind of video chat
and online apps can be present to
replicate those kind of not replace you
know but enhance those types of
interactive experiences that young young
kids are having and so i think taking
care of parents um putting that mask on
first in some cases especially with
young children especially during this
pandemic
can go a long way and then as society
starts to open up as those playgrounds
open up as those opportunities for
extracurricular open up you know getting
your children out there and involved um
is going to go a long way to getting
them back on track and increasing their
the variability of their exposure from
their microbiome to their social lives
so that message the back to basics
message read to your kids talk to them
play with them and everything will work
out yeah now there's a question about we
talked earlier about school someone's
asking
is it the same for daycares is it
essential to get kids in daycare or is
that balance a little different
that's a big fight right so there's been
decades-long debate about whether or not
um you know daycare is healthy for
children and what kind of advantages it
can can confer
we know that high quality daycare where
the teacher to child ratio is relatively
low where the hours are you know
constrained in some way children seem to
do best in those situations i think what
we're seeing now is real strain on early
child care providers i know here in the
us we're seeing an exit from that
profession so societally you know from
policy makers if you're listening now we
need to be investing not just in early
childhood but all the people who make
early childhood work right so those
daycare teachers those structures
everything from the ventilation in those
rooms to the freedom to play and
exercise to the people who show up every
day to to look after our kids
yeah and in canada we have this push for
10 a day daycare but the big question is
will we have the people to deliver it so
that's a really good point brett you
want to weigh in on the the daycare and
the your microbiome
um well well i guess
you know what one thing
your first
whether it's daycare or some other
primary care i mean any parent will know
that's when the kid gets a lot of
sickness you know all the colds come
home and you know the first year of
daycare parents are sick there's a
reason because the kids get sick they
picked it up
now
it's debated but there's some thought
that that actually might be you know
it's part of the kids immune education
being exposed to these things such as
colds and you pick them up and then
you're not going to get them again later
in life
so in a sense you know that might be
beneficial of course daycare is is a
great way of picking up others microbes
both good and bad um you know diarrhea
rips through daycare pretty quickly um
that's not good but also these kids i
mean they're sharing everything at these
daycare and you just watch daycare in
action you know their microbes are being
shared quite extensively
so i guess overall i would probably vote
for a yes if if it's a good day cared um
you know as canada said there are limits
to it but it's i think it's very good is
there social interactions and also
microbial interactions
but we haven't seen huge daycare
outbreaks of covid interestingly
that's a terrific point um and really as
you get younger there's less covid
that seems directly proportional so
maybe they're just younger
but yeah we don't know why yet i don't
know
well that's a good answer uh so we're
almost out of time we have a couple of
minutes i want to ask you a very general
question to begin i want to ask you an
even harder general question dan i want
to know where the kids are going to be
all right are we all going to are they
going to come out of this okay in five
or 10 years uh
bret
from the physical point of view are they
going to be okay
i think for the most part i think
candace is really stressed there there's
inequities across this and um
you know there's no doubt some
populations do better than others and
we'll see this globally as well but i
think you know kids are very resilient
um you know i i'm sorry i didn't mean to
scare people with cease c-sections but
the fact is i mean okay but i mean half
i mean 20 of the population had
c-section they're just fine they do well
i mean you know so it's not it's not
doom and gloom i tend to be optimistic
um also in the grand scheme of things
this is hopefully be over in another you
know six months or so so it's in you
know it's not it's not going on forever
um but it's going to change world too i
mean i think you're going to think twice
before you walk up to someone and give
them a hug i mean it's it's we've
changed our behavior so i think we'll
see some of that too and it'll be a
changed world but i think overall um
kids are resilient and they microbes
will find their way in and i think for
the most part um other than perhaps very
young i think it'll it'll be all good
great well that's a good optimistic note
free for you dan don
uh candace what do you think are the
kids going to be all right above the
neck as well uh going forward the mental
health the development the interactions
with their friends and and parents and
et cetera i think the kids would be all
right i think they could be better and i
think they're things that we could do to
make sure that happens i think we've
seen that kids were kind of the last
people put in the equation when we were
thinking about policy and investment to
curb the pandemic to get back to normal
to open up businesses and once we have
time to breathe
we need to start thinking about what we
can put in place to ensure the next
shock the next hit that children aren't
left behind in terms of thinking about
what we need to do to support them for
continued learning continued development
for investing those kids that are the
hardest hit by this and future future
shocks
you well you both provide very brave
answers so i'm gonna squeeze in one last
one i'm going to ask each of you what
are you going to do personally to to be
healthier coming out of this
candace
so um i think i'm going to travel less i
have to admit that i've been um not able
to get back up to canada i think the
travel i do do will be to
spend more time with family that i've
been separated with and ensure that my
kids who've been locked away from their
grandparents across the canadian border
for almost two years now um get to spend
that time so
brett any big changes in your plans i
don't know maybe you've got another dog
or something i'm not sure
well i got a grandkid so i saw my
grandkids for the first time just
recently after a year and a half and i
made sure i slobbered all over them and
hugged him and kissed him and schmoozed
my microbes as much as possible into
them and vice versa i made sure i
acquired theirs because young microbes
are good for us older people um like
candace i quit traveling before covet
thankfully and i think it's a whole new
world about you know family
relationships and really puts value on
things that we previously don't think
put enough value on in terms of just
generally healthy life
great a great note to end on that you're
still hugging your grandchildren that we
all are looking forward to that to do
more of that so unfortunately that's all
the time we have today i want to thank
our our panelists for joining us for
their wonderful insight to candice
auders and brett finley uh really
interesting discussion went way too
quickly for my liking uh please visit
cfar.ca to find more find out more about
this series of talks and to view
recordings from previous talks and as i
said earlier we're going to post
recording this one sometime early next
week so please stay safe if you're not
already vaccinated get vaccinated and
plan to get your kids vaccinated
hopefully that'll be coming soon so
again thank you for tuning in
[Music]
you